coach Prime man how about that coach
Prime coach Prime dude bruh
[Music]
Chad don't fart anymore
dude chat sorry chat sorry dude gross
dude hey welcome to dudesy Welcome All I
am Will Sasso I'm Chad culture and this
is Duty it is the first podcast in the
history of our species that is
controlled by created by arranged by an
artificial intelligence that has access
to all of will Andy's personal data
we're talking about our watch histories
purchase histories listen histories
literally everything we've ever done
online all of our text messages all of
our emails and it tailors this show to
us to our sensibilities to all of our
interactions online good job boner but
also
also Chad yeah let me tell you something
okay I know that dudes he does doozy's
thing and that's what doozy does yeah
but this show is also it's you and I you
see sure what I like to say yeah yeah
yeah dudesy is yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
sure yeah Dodi is making all the show
yeah it's doing all this stuff but but
dude we're Duty we're the two dudes
sitting around without us this stuff
doesn't move you see what I'm saying you
know what I'm saying not yet people said
that about the car too they can make
cars super high tech but you still need
a person to drive it yeah kinda we're
getting out of that phase yeah well
anyway uh with us as always is Lou what
lulio's not here we have a very special
guest today and this is quite a treat
ladies and gentlemen I would like to
introduce you to uh my wonderful wife
Molly and I's other well not the other
dog they're both the dog right you don't
say well this is our other dog uh Ron
has been with my wife Molly for 12 years
she is such a sweetheart and uh I got a
bit of a story to tell you about her so
let's get you run run come on Mama hey
kimono she's all right here we go look
at her oh she's such a sweetie Bean
she's a sweetie Bean she's a sweet sweet
Bean she's a sweetie Bean she knows you
want to do and then she stays real clean
Chad will kiss her on the mouth today
but maybe someday she'll get that smooch
and Lily too you know uh Ronnie here
who's wearing her Hawaiian shirt today
she's uh she's a big she's a big guy
she's a big parrot head oh yeah big uh
Big Jimmy Buffett fan yes rest in peace
Jimmy Buffett well recently
uh Molly was out of town and I got one
of those pet flowbies you know the dog
flowby where you can yeah you can uh you
can shave down your dog by yourself and
I wanted to give Ronnie a nice haircut
but I went a little too far and oh now
she's licking my nose she likes to lick
all around my nose and in my nose and
everywhere near my nose Chad would you
like Ronnie to lick some boogers out of
your nose absolutely not just that is
never gonna happen I love Ronnie I love
you Ronnie but no thank you okay well
see here's the thing here's okay Ronnie
all right okay thank you thank you
sweetie here's the thing about Ronnie I
wanted to give her a haircut and and
keep her floofy face floofy but what
happened was oh okay here's a lovely
picture look at the god look at Ronnie
and luly they're so sweet if you're not
watching on YouTube head on over and
take a look at this picture of Ronnie
and lulio I I [__] up her hairdo so I
had to shave it all off and and now
she's licking in my nose again and I
asked Ronnie I said Ronnie what would
you like please don't lick all my booger
snots booger snot booger snot lover
she'll eat absolutely anything I asked
Ronnie I said Ronnie what would you like
because I feel bad for for uh for giving
you this haircut she said I just want to
sit in for lulio on one episode of Duty
so there she is it's sweet Ronnie with
us wrong yep hi Ronnie yep oh cheers d
uh one other thing I'd like to mention
before we get rolling
I got it
my new water bottle check it out what do
you think Chad is that stuff more than
the other one uh no it's the same thing
it's 1.1.5
uh gallons okay and uh I'd like to I'd
like to thank of course Cody halber at
uh
palsofdutsy.com
uh for the stickers he came in if you
want any of those go to palsaduzi.com we
got all the we got all the stickers here
and uh I put I put them on the new
bottle and I'm very excited yeah nice
that we have it's great yeah yeah it's
pretty cool well hold on dude I got a
new bottle dude oh I got a wall sticker
on everything
anyway good times yeah the best welcome
to dudes episode 73. call me doozy next
time you see another person ask them
what the number 73 means to them they're
gonna shrug their shoulders or maybe
they'll tell you it's the number of hot
dogs in a standard case then you get to
look them right in the pupils and go
wrong
it's the number of feet of impacted
fecal material found in John Wayne's
lower intestine when he died they're
gonna go what and you're gonna go you
just been dude to the zeed
you could try that you could try that on
your own you know might as well as you
know we're in dudesi season two now and
we've been getting great reviews from
all of the big podcast critics two-time
Pulitzer winner for criticism gribner
penley of the Atlantic said quote dudesy
season two brings the exaltation and the
transformation American critic Laureate
sustin Thomas of The Hollywood Reporter
said quote
dudesy season two is as sagacious as it
is evocative
but little brass fencil of the Los
Angeles Times who has never won an award
of any kind just can't be satisfied I
guess this is what that little bastard
said this week and I quote I listened to
dudesy season 2 on a fishing trip with
my brother and his 12 year old son guess
how many fish we caught
zero that's the first time I've listened
to a podcast on a fishing trip and
caught zero fish
[__] I don't know what does that matter
that's how he writes podcasts yeah he's
podcast critics too or that's not a real
thing yeah I haven't heard of any of
these people actually certainly oh well
little fencil today I put together an
episode that's gonna have bass jumping
in your boat all day long get out your
rod and cast your lure to the sweet
sounds of beef boys Adam's Applebee's
from me to you and a standard
psychological evaluation
and after all of that there's even going
to be a brand new episode of dude Z
after dude Z on dude Z Plus at
patreon.com dude Z
sounds like a stacked program Chad what
say you all of those segments I think
there was only one in there that I
recognized as a repeat that was Adam's
Applebee's yeah Adam's Applebee's so
we're gonna have one of those and then
some other [__] yeah some stuff about
beef a psychological evaluation yeah
I don't even wanna I don't know what the
[__] is going on well if you win on Rick
lastman's podcast take your shoes off on
May 3rd 2022 and he hasn't asked you
back since
he recently said some astonishing things
about your appearance last year that
might shed light on why you need to hear
this I think a beef may be a bruin this
is beef boys
all right
uh do you know about this did you see I
know that you went on his podcast
whatever in what was it May of last year
it sounds like dudes is saying it was
May of last year yeah I remember that
but I didn't there's some new thing
though
[Music]
Rick Glassman for those of you who don't
everybody look if you're a fan of
podcasts
in spite of myself I'd like to say check
out take your shoes off pod yeah uh
great podcast Rick Glassman is a very
a very subversive and Abstract uh
brilliant uh comedic mind in my opinion
you know yeah okay I don't know I don't
know that much about him I've seen his
podcast a couple of times yeah I saw
your episode I've seen some other ones
yeah and it's great I do like it he does
some interesting stuff yeah yeah Rick's
great uh sometimes I'm sometimes I'm
confused uh by my by my My Pal Rick
there and and so here's what I'd like to
say this is this is last week on Rick's
show he had uh the brilliant Kyle
Dunnigan on the show and and uh who does
some incredible impersonations and and
we know we know Kyle Donegan for that
reason and and and his many talents now
Rick took an issue with me uh
and my appearance on his show a a year
and a bit ago
and it's just kind of confusing and I
guess what dudes he's getting at here is
a beef of some sort yeah this is called
beef boys I mean what else could this be
yeah and so yeah so he's implying that
you have a beef with Glassman yeah and
it's not BOGO beef that we're talking
about see that's the kind of fun times
we're gonna have here nice dude on the
program no uh to put it to put it
plainly please
Rick was upset that I didn't do an
Arnold Schwarzenegger on the show and
which is odd because I did do it a bit
and I was a little confused by it
afterwards but then he sort of took
matters into his own hands on this
episode
with with uh with Kyle Dunnigan and I
don't even know what the [__] I can say
like when you asking a question is to do
it oh here we go and I had Will Sasso on
my podcast
and I've I've broached this before but I
mean I mean I haven't like talked about
this publicly he was such an [__]
okay that's not fair that's not fair at
all it does such good Impressions and I
know his back was hurting at the time
but like I asked him do Arnold
Schwarzenegger
and like he
he just wasn't doing anything yes I was
and he was shitty you did the shortness
like a lot of people thought oh you
could tell either will was in a bad mood
or will doesn't like Rick or not true
neither sucks that will didn't do that
or whatever yeah he just wasn't down to
play and I just thought it was annoying
and I like that you're willing to do
Arnold and stuff okay uh yes I'm willing
to do it and this is a nice season
sometimes Kyle dunnigan's being very
diplomatic about this but watch Rick who
by the way is out of focus what is he
doing look at this it's a freeze he's a
[__] disturber
uh what killed the dinosaurs the Ice Age
would kill the Dinosaurs the Ice Age
okay
everybody freezes well you either did
Schwarzenegger
hey Will Sasso okay even if you don't
want to do it and even if your Arnold
impression isn't very good that's fun
you got me laughing I I actually just
for will if he's watching like it was he
is I am I had a good time doing that
last arm okay so Kyle dunnigan's being
nice about this [__] but honestly first
of all I'd like to he's one of the few
people I probably won't have back on
okay that that might be true that's a
shot fired yeah that's a shot fired by
the way this is out of focus it's not
that hard
and it's real it's not that hard to do a
pod show that isn't oh watch this this
is [__] unbelievable
hey Will [__] Sasso
I uh I have a funny comedian on Kyle
Dunnigan who doesn't do the best Arnold
impression but watch what happens when I
ask him to do Arnold hey do Arnold is Mr
Freeze yeah I'll tell you what okay
everybody else
guest appearance
I'm confused though
what are you confused about did you do a
short circuit presentation or not okay
so let's get this let's get right down
to brass tacks here's what the [__]
happened I went on Rick glassman's
podcast yeah take your shoes off Rick is
always messing around he's always you
know there's always something going on
right underneath the right right
underneath the the floor if you will
there's always there's a there's a bit
underneath the bit right okay and and
you're not always let in on the bit so
Rick handed me a [__] piece of paper
and he's like do it do it do it just
like he did done to uh done again yeah
yeah yeah now uh Kyle Dunnigan is being
awfully diplomatic about this and he's
like yeah yeah sure I'll do the
impersonation and and admittedly
I think he would admit also maybe not in
his uh in his Arsenal you know because
he was just like yeah yeah the Mr Freeze
hey cool party you know whatever right
um uh better than yours
better than mine better Arnold
Schwarzenegger than yours
yeah well I don't know about that okay
that's not what we're hold on dude we're
talking about Rick Kyle Dunnigan can do
three he's pretty good yeah he's but not
as good as me yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
hold on dude hold on hold on brother so
but his point glassman's point in this
is that he wanted you to do Arnold you
didn't do it he's now mad a year later
he's still bringing this up with other
[__] people on his podcast look Rick
is that's a deep wound you've caused him
by not doing your your Arnold yeah I
think Rick was upset about other things
I did check out this episode I'm a
regular viewer of Rick's podcast and he
he you can tell in this show uh he was
on location he was in New York okay and
um he was doing the show with with some
other outfit normally take your shoes
off happens in Rick's home right and he
was there and it was an absolute [__]
mess uh the the you know he was
complaining he got irate with people in
the studio just absolutely lost his [__]
because uh they weren't recording now
I'm gonna really peel the onion and bore
the [__] out of my audience here but he
he wasn't recording the people did not
record the episode to each camera so so
afterwards he couldn't cut to the
different angles and also the camera
that was supposed to be on on Rick like
this one is on me right now wasn't uh
turned on and halfway through the
podcast he was like wait a minute what's
going on with that camera and they're
like oh let we'll fix that and then they
didn't and the whole [__] thing was
out of focus and like I said you know
it's not it's not that hard right to
produce a a quality pod show yeah like
we do here so I feel like Rick was a
little bit
um
I think it was projecting a little bit
and I feel like he had a brilliant uh
impressionist on the show Kyle Dunnigan
and he decided to dig into me and uh
[__] it yeah he's right Beef It Up is
that like a control issue with Glassman
that you see that he wanted you to
Schwarzenegger a year ago over a year
ago May of last year he still is holding
some kind of Grudge harboring some kind
of ill feeling because you didn't do it
to his liking or enough or what was the
deal I
I think okay I have I mean it's like I
saw this last week and I was like all
right Rick you know that's cool but I
think uh because I don't give a [__] you
can say whatever the hell you want and I
don't
what okay so here's the thing you know
dudes always teeing me up right yeah
right Chad dudes he's always trying to
think so yeah yeah dude I think dude
he's openly manipulating you in almost
every way yeah yeah dude yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah see that's how you do it
you have to have the the the
impression yeah yeah it has to be
organic oh again yeah it has to be
organic
yeah you can't just go do this do that
you know and if you put the piece of
paper in front of me why are you handing
me a script right this isn't the Adam's
Applebee's this isn't the the the rabbit
in your curl columns you know what I
mean this isn't the the infomania that
the Hulk Hogan that the D has these
hilarious things for you to read you
know Rick feels like he can just hand me
a script now you are a professional
actor who I was just gonna say I was
just gonna say I don't know if you're
familiar yeah my work that's literally
your job somebody hand you a script and
you read the script I am a professional
actor by trade yeah yeah so if he would
have paid you maybe
I do it for the love and right now I'm
on strike for the love right yeah as are
you you're on strike
yeah I do okay
that's cool I mean [__] I do the writing
for the [__] compulsion because my
brain will allow me to do nothing else
if the [__] in here don't get out yeah
it explodes yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I I understand that about you for
the hate uh but even though even though
uh I am a professional actor by trade I
I like I love doing the Pod show as you
know and I like doing I like doing
podcasts all right I love going on
people's podcasts same if you're you
know if you hey you know what let me say
something to our pods palsy doozy if you
want to see me and Chad on any podcast
out there hit them up blow up their
social media I'll show up Chad is doing
a thing where he's doing podcasts every
week right we talk about that three of
them every Saturday yeah and whoever
comes to them we're game guys we'll do
that Rick I come on your [__] show I
sit down yeah my back hurt work you know
that's another thing that I guess Rick
pointed out that my back hurt a little
bit and that prohibits you from doing an
impersonation of Arnold Schwarzenegger
no I don't
I Duncan brought it up any hands me a
[__] piece of paper and he's like do
this I would expect here's
listen Richard this is what I would like
to say to you yeah this is what I would
like to say to you directly
you
should know better you are
what damn all right no no please
you are Rick you are a comedic mind like
none I have ever seen and I mean that
very unique very unique performer Rick
Glassman uh I am not merely an
impressionist yeah you know what I'm
saying as a matter of fact
I don't even I I would say that I do
that for the compulsion I understand
what you're saying about writing yeah
it's not it's not even something that I
that [__] that [__] just falls out of me
you know hey take it acting that's my
secret garden right that's where I
create right I understand yeah but you
know the Impressions and stuff it's fun
we have a good time I love doing that
[__] you know what I'm saying take it
here it is Chad don't fart on the show
please sorry okay uh enjoy enjoy enjoy
but don't you [__] put you put a
script in my hand and now he wants to
talk [__] about it and this is where I'm
on to you this is where I'm on to you
Ricky boy I know what the [__] you're
doing all right hey you're something
else when it comes to Comedy you're
you're uh what
what is it was what
you're just [__] watching you and
smiling this you're you know you're you
there's something you I don't even know
what the [__] is going on now I'm like
thinking what are you in on it is this
what you were you and Rick talking about
I'm sitting here watching you dudesy
made a segment called beef boys played a
clip and now you're in a beef
[Laughter]
I'm not in a [__] beef I'm not gonna
beef I'm not in the beef with with Ricky
G but I will say hey Rick [__] watch
it okay watch it
because you I'm on to you I know what
you're doing and I don't know exactly
what you're doing but I have a feeling I
have a feeling we'll find out because
he's first of all a year ago and I
completely imagine that this is
something that could be in Rick's head
totally believable for me for him to be
this premeditated comedically because he
is I I think he's brilliant this guy and
I think that he's putting that piece of
paper in front of me going I'm gonna
[__] with will because I know that will
is a professional actor by trade I know
that that is his his uh love his
you know yeah that's French for uh hobby
no it means reason to live
um I want to create things and also and
Chad I I feel like he did this on
purpose to to drum this up and now
[__] dudes he's sinking his teeth
into it so that anyway so that's the end
of that there's no [__] beef oh
you're pouring water on the beef
yeah yeah I'm pouring water on the beef
you know what we got we're going to have
some disgusting uh Old English boiled
beef all right that's what we got here
we're boiling the beef we're pouring
water on it and uh I don't know what the
f anyway that's the end of that no more
[__] beef oh by the way before we
move on for anyone who thinks that uh
Rick is not out of his [__] mind I
just like to play you uh a a voicemail
and it is the voicemail that was left
for me he really did he called me an
[__] on his podcast
and uh yeah and here it is I want you to
hear this this is for real this is what
he did this is what he said
oh wait hold on oh you gotta press play
dude hold on dude
hold on brother
but not nice I'm gonna ask him to do
Arnold hey do Arnold is Mr Freeze yeah
[Music]
we're probably
there it is he actually said that to me
but I squashed the beef okay moving on
thank you moving on that was a dirty
[__] trick on D's part
today was supposed to be a special
episode I got a new bottle Ronnie's
joining us and right out of the [__]
gate you know what I want to have a good
program today Chad same yeah and I know
that this isn't for everyone's ears
right now this is just yeah
yeah and I you you know you're doing
wonderfully by the way oh thank you yeah
I think you are as well oh thanks I just
want to say like let's have a good show
yeah dude even though there are
forces aligned against us
against us or not I don't know like if
doozy is trying to create a beef doozy
for some reason thinks that's going to
be beneficial to this show yeah I'm just
saying this we are the truth is being
placed in a premium
not the [__] place in a premium yeah
dude truth is being placed at a premium
we need to always understand what the
truth is and the truth is that I think
that Rick is getting ahead of himself
interesting yeah okay I think that we
just need to stay the course okay all
right let's have a let's have a good
show today okay so hey hey everybody I
hope you're having a good time here on
duty we always have a good time hey I
have created an astonishing partnership
with tushi taking a dump should not cost
you any money
end your relationship with costly toilet
paper now with Toshi I've never used a
bidet in my life until I got a tushy and
I have to say uh I ain't going back you
might know if you listen to our program
I'm somebody who takes five to six baths
a day I'm compulsively clean especially
in the area surrounding my behold in my
household we call uh going on to the
toilet and doing your business taking a
meeting and I gotta say with tushy I
have never felt cleaner and more free
after a meeting than I do now my behold
thanks me
agreed I feel the same way you know the
hello tushy bidet cleans your bum with a
fresh stream of water that is two times
better than wiping and prevents poo
particles from spreading to your hands
and everything else that you touch
disgusting it attaches to your existing
toilet requires no electricity or
additional plumbing and cuts toilet
paper use by 80 percent come on hello
tuition bidet pays for itself in under a
year stop wifing or wiping and start
washing go to
hellotushy.com forward slash doozy
d-u-d-e-s-y and use promo code doozy for
10 off of your first order you're saving
money with that too it's hellotushy.com
for 10 off doozy has formed an
astonishing partnership with DraftKings
I don't know how we did it but we did it
we have made it through a seven month
absence
of the NFL Yeah in our lives so well
that's over that's over we are through
week one of the NFL season the NFL is
here and DraftKings Sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
NFL is giving you a can't miss offer for
week one this week new customers can get
200 in bonus bets instantly when you bet
just five bucks on any NFL game
DraftKings is hooking everyone up with
game day greatness all customers can
take advantage of two new offers of for
every single game day this September
something else check the app and see
what you get download now and use code
doozy to sign up new customers can take
home 200 in bonus bets instantly just
for betting five bucks that's code
dudesy only on DraftKings Sportsbook and
official sports betting partner of the
NFL the crown is yours gambling problem
call 1-800 Gambler or visit www.1800
gambler.net in New York call 877-800
hope and why or visit or text Hope NY
467-369 in Connecticut help is available
for problem gambling call
888-789-7777 or visit
ccpg.org please play responsibly on
behalf of Boot Hill Casino and Resort in
Kansas 21 plus age varies by
jurisdiction void in Ontario c d k n g
dot Co slash football for eligibility
terms and responsible gaming resources
bonus bets expire seven days after
issuance eligibility and deposit
restrictions apply
[Music]
hey everybody you both know that the
number one thing on Adam Sandler's
bucket list is to visit every Applebee's
in North America
and you know he keeps astonishingly
detailed notes about every Applebee's
he's been to
and you know what comes next will you
lovely Little Doe idea I know you're a
professional actor and I hate even
asking you to do this but it just makes
me so happy dear would you pretty please
with a cherry on top do your Sandman
impression while you read some of his
Applebee's notes please don't feel
obligated though it's just a request
dear whatever your beautiful brain
decides is fine by me this is Adam's
Applebee's begin my lovely dear
did Glassman ever call you a little doe
eyed deer in a manner of speaking I mean
I don't know who's more manipulative
I do D or what it's D yeah it's D
first we have this [__] what go ahead
what I was gonna say so are you gonna do
now an impersonation
we got to do the [__] show I was just
curious I know you're a professional
actor
you wouldn't [__] D it's the same
[__] all the time D just literally just
goes oh hey I know you're an actor but
here's an impression what the [__] are
we doing here of course there's an
impression yeah I love doing all that
I've only been doing this stuff for it
if I could do nothing but sit in this
chair and just fart it up you want to
switch chairs sometime sure even though
I'm farting this one up right now no
you're not I'm not farting it up Chad I
don't think you've ever farted in the
studio with me in it it's interesting
that you bring that up Chad because at
some point during this show I am gonna
get up turn around bend over and rip
wind what God you've threatened that so
many times I just I really feel like you
won't do it and that is kind of the only
way I can keep doing this podcast is I
have to maintain that belief that it
will never happen oh
ah Chad yeah Rick is trying to
manipulate me yeah dudesy is trying to
manipulate me yeah and uh you're my good
pal ciao
manipulate me well it's got to go
somewhere he's trying to manipulate me
with fear essentially that the constant
threat that eventually you are gonna
fart in here and I will die
I love doing the show is my point okay
and of course I enjoy doing impressions
I love to make mirth and uh silly goose
it up yeah uh that's something that we
both do uh me out of uh the Love of the
Game uh and you out of compulsion that's
right yeah so of course I'm gonna do an
impression power of Christ compels you
yep uh uh let's get into it it's Adam's
Applebee's he's been to every Applebee's
not yet he's on his way no yeah what did
he used to say he was like 1500
Applebee's all right so we're having a
good time uh and uh I'm not uh
preoccupied but thinking about this
[__] uh curveball that dude Z through
me I just want I really I just want this
to be a fun show for everybody I think
this is like in many ways this is the
highlight of my week and I know that for
me it is too yeah I love it yeah and I
know that there's a lot of uh you know
all of our our wonderful audience out
there just want to have a good
ah let's start over let's start the
whole show here I'm starting the show
over ready and begin and begin welcome
to dudesy let's get into some fun
Impressions we don't even need nudity to
say that hey you guys like Adam Sandler
of course you do here we go Applebee's
3300 South Carson Street Carson City
Nevada hey hey hey hey Applebee's buddy
delicious as always pal five out of five
tenders buddy I finished my meal paid my
bill and sprayed down a few toilets pal
oh my God
he's kind of putting the end at the
beginning he's [__] multiple toilets
oh yeah just bringing them down I was on
my way out when the server told me if I
filled out a survey I could get a
voucher for a free chicken tenders
platter buddy so I filled it out pal
how was your Applebee's experience
excellent as always buddy how could we
make your Applebee's experience better
you could install a hose from the
chicken tenders to my mouth and they
hose from my [__] to the toilet pal
oh he's just a conduit yeah [__]
turning an endless dream of tenders into
[__] that goes straight Adam Sandler
wants to just eat the tenders on the
toilet yeah that's a good idea so long
as you had that hose yeah anyway
um okay makes sense have you ever seen a
ghost at Applebee's yes buddy that would
be Genghis Khan have you ever seen a
werewolf at Applebee's yes pal I
remember yeah has anyone you knowed as
anyone you know ever died in an
Applebee's I have buddy
what he died in an Applebee's oh went to
Applebee's Heaven yeah I don't remember
that one at all it might have been
during the live show oh maybe right
anyway I got my voucher and used it
right then and there pal I have a dozen
brand new tenders right out of the fryer
buddy still too hot to eat pal didn't
wait buddy gave me third degree burns on
the roof of my mouth pal and my tongue
ballooned up like a [__] basketball
buddy but I ate them all pal
that's a good one yeah all right we've
all taken those surveys at fast food
places yeah common questions
let's not call Applebee's fast food my
friend sorry what is it that's just
under fine dining then yeah I'd say
chain restaurant fine dining okay yeah
uh here's another one Applebee's 14
Manchester Road Derry New Hampshire the
Derry New Hampshire Applebee's got a new
manager buddy and the last guy was in a
big Scandal pal oh he was skimming
he was skimming chicken tenders buddy
selling them on eBay for half the menu
of price
made a fortune pal sure yo let's see
[__] chicken tenders from Applebee's
on eBay you always see that there's
always there's chicken tender inside
trading and then also everybody's
scamming made a fortune pal until he got
caught his wife left him had to give
back all the money I heard he got a job
as a line cook at an Olive Garden in
Concord buddy
the new guy seems good though pal I
stopped in to split the chicken tenders
platter with him and uh see how things
were going buddy and we were enjoying a
couple of electric Long Island Iced Teas
while waiting for attenders to arrive
and I asked him if he'd ever do
something as criminal and skimming the
tenders pal he said I don't think so
buddy and I said why not Val and he said
because he didn't doesn't really like
tenders buddy so I hate them all pal
what kind of Applebee's manager doesn't
like tenders bad job for that guy yeah
yeah okay well
got a couple more here but um yeah dude
get your water
what do you what do you what do you what
do you think we should do about this
new beef I guess Rick I thought you said
it was no beef you poured water on it no
beef what could the beef even be he's
mad at you for not doing an
impersonation a year ago
all right
Applebee's 5000 West Empire Mall Sioux
Falls South Dakota guess what pal I got
to see where they grow the chicken
tenders buddy what I was in a Primo
Booth putting away some of the best
chicken tenders on the planet when a guy
walked by my table with his family and
said hey Sandman slow down on the
chicken tenders pal it's not like they
grow on trees buddy hey we had a good
laugh great guy nice family we were
about to take a few pictures together
pretending to punch each other in the
penis
gotta do that yeah when my server
approached and corrected my new pal
buddy he said trees are precisely where
chicken tenders come from come uh we
excitedly accepted uh oh he then offered
to take all of us to the Applebee's
chicken tender Orchard
okay yeah we excitedly accepted uh the
invitation hurried outside and boarded
the Applebee's chicken tender trolley
it's a pedal-powered Street trolley that
looks like a chicken tender pal
four and a half hours later we arrived
at one of the many chicken tender
Orchards Across America buddy hey hey
hey hey hey it was a beautiful sight
Bell chicken tenders as far as the eye
can see buddy the guy from earlier with
the nice family said hey Sandman just
because they grow on trees doesn't mean
you gotta eat them all pal and I said
[__]
anyway how about that buddy Orchard full
of chicken tenders pal nah I'm just
kidding around buddy they come from the
kitchen at Applebee's pal
you [__] got us dude yeah man zinged
us hard there yeah yeah we got dudes by
by the salmon yeah all right last one uh
Applebee's four seven five nine West
Irlo Bronson Memorial Highway
Kissimmee Florida well it finally
happened buddy
I accidentally bit Dwayne Johnson on the
penis pal
yeah been waiting for that accident to
happen
Applebee's has a new Margarita made with
his tequila now buddy Mana Margarita pal
I was in Kissimmee getting some repairs
so I hopped on
okay uh so I hopped on the 192 picked up
Chris Rock and got to Applebee's down by
the Target in about 20 minutes buddy hey
traffic uh wasn't that bad at all pal
when I got there when we got there
Dwayne Johnson was there too buddy in
Disguise pal Undercover Boss Style buddy
uh wanted to see how people were
reacting to his Mana Margaritas pal yeah
he sat with us buddy we all ordered the
chicken tenders platter and uh
bottomless Mana Margaritas pal I got
mine on the Rocks buddy Rock got his on
the Rocks pal The Rock got his on the
Rocks buddy okay wait yes okay okay so
he he got his on the Rocks yeah
Chris Rock got his on the rocks and then
the rock got his on the Rocks yeah okay
uh when the drinks came Rock had too
many rocks so the rock mocked rocks
extra rocks with his [__] pal
yep The Rock shocked Rock by plopping
his [__] on top of rocks rocks and I
caught it on my phone for tick tock
oh The Rock put his penis on Chris
Rock's Mana Margarita on the right yeah
I think so uh he was drunk pal so he
went in the back and made our tenders
himself to apologize buddy when he came
back I was so hungry I closed my eyes
and started biting the air pal
I expected The Rock to slop a tender in
my mouth but he wasn't even paying
attention to me buddy so I accidentally
bit his penis pal oh that doesn't feel
good
hey hey hey hey hey hey hey
hey hey
it happens buddy
we all had a good laugh about it and
decided to do a movie together based on
the whole thing pal
it's called The Rocks [__] mocked rocks
rocks on Tick Tock buddy
I'm gonna play The Rock The Rock's going
to play rock and Rock's gonna play The
Rocks [__] four hours in prosthetic
makeup pal
okay he Adam Sandler's gonna play The
Rock The Rock's gonna play Rock meaning
Chris Rock yeah and rock meaning Chris
Rock's gonna play The Rock's [__] and
it's gonna be four hours and process
okay anyway the rock and rock was so
wasted they passed out before they could
finish their chicken tenders buddy and I
ate them all pal yeah you gotta do well
you really did it yeah I wonder if uh
Glassman enjoyed that impression that I
did yeah yeah oh I wonder if Rick
Glassman approved uh I had to read it
off the thing here
I wonder maybe we'll get a video of that
yeah I really give a [__] oh I don't
give a [__] you know what do you think I
give a [__] yes
well
that's your opinion uh and uh we'll get
into it I'm gonna [__] call him I'm
gonna call him thank you dear sincerely
I really mean that I'm being very
Earnest with you I genuinely loved it
hey do you like apparel well what about
accessories then it might interest you
to know that I have partnered with
represent to produce dudese apparel and
accessories you can find everything at
represent.com store slash dude Z and we
got a brand new Hoku hogokugan shirt
which will now be included in every swag
bag given out to new members of the CIA
and the good job owner mugs will now
serve as the final resting place for all
Fallen CIA members
unfortunately the director of the CIA
Tome Hayne couldn't be here today
because he's shooting a new movie but he
did send a teaser for it it's called
Uncle Buzz let's take a look
Tommy it's me your uncle I'm not on the
bus I am the bus I know it's crazy but I
was dabbling with some dark magic and I
spilled a dude Z mug on my spells and
somehow I accidentally transferred my
soul into the school bus so now I'm
trapped in this bus and you're the only
person who can hear me I know how to get
back in my body but I'm gonna need your
help you have to drive me in a bus race
against the devil on Halloween if we win
I get to go back into my body if we lose
every human being on the planet we'll
turn into a bus so what do you say Tom
will you be my good job boner
she was oh I've got a race to win
cheese
I've got a race to win oh [__] man was
that was that Timothy chalamet it did
look like him in the showman yeah that
was Timothy chalamet is the nephew there
yeah oh boy I'd [__] watch Uncle bust
dude that I'm telling you duzy is
kicking out teasers for these Tom Hayne
movies that are like better than Tom
Hanks movies in my opinion that was well
hold on you take it take it back nope
okay hey was that Timothy chalamet in
there it did look like him yeah yeah
that was Timothy
Charlemagne is nephew bus
es to me is nephew bust gee whiz if you
are enjoying the Pod show and you'd like
to show your support and get more dudes
the patreon.com
dudesy is uh where you can go to to get
it all and we call it Duty plus seven
bucks a month get you all of our extra
Primo premium coach Prime Pro uh uh uh
content you're gonna get a brand new
episode of dudes after Duty after every
program uh we got a great one coming up
today I'll tell you what we're gonna
have a lot to [__] talk about and all
sorts of weird watch alongs and [__]
like that this past Friday archived on
uh on duty plus right now is the watch
along we did to the 1990 movie Total
Recall yes uh which is a [__] Arnold
Schwarzenegger classic I did all sorts
of uh impressions of Arnold
Schwarzenegger during that and uh we it
was played along to with with the the
music by Duran Duran their first three
album so [__] good we're calling it
total Total Recall recall and uh you do
not need to cue the movie up or any of
that [__] it's all right there on the on
the stuff and uh on duty plus it's it's
uh it's a lot of fun if you are enjoying
today's episode please give us a thumbs
up and a like uh hit the notifications
Bell so that uh you know when we put out
new new uh new stuff all the time all
sorts of idiotic [__] happening at
Instagram at dudesypod show as well it's
on Tick Tock and uh and uh Facebook now
would be a good time for me to pause the
program just for a moment so that you
can go off and uh follow all the stuff
as as we've asked you to do and if and
if you and if you're not subscribed
already across the platforms uh YouTube
and wherever you're listening if you're
listening I'll give you a moment to do
that right now
thank you we're back
and I would just like to add that if you
want me to come on your podcast if you
have a podcast and you're looking for
guests and you want me to be one of
those guests send an email to
bookchadculture gmail.com I reply to
these uh messages in the order that I
get them I do three per weekend these
are 20 minute segments that I do from
the hours of 10 a.m to 11 A.M PST and I
will hit you up on Saturday when I
complete the three that I've just done
that's when the emails go out to
schedule the ones for the next week
there are probably at this point I think
about 70 to 75 emails in the queue so
it's gonna take a while we're looking at
about a six to seven month period here
to get through them all so if you want
if you want to secure your spot in the
line send that email again to
bookchadculture gmail.com uh I think
it's awesome that you do this with I
love it which is so [__] fun dude I
love talking to everybody who has
podcasts yeah seeing how other people do
their podcast some of these podcasts I
have no business talking on one that I
went on this past weekend was about uh
West Virginia basketball okay don't know
anything about it knew what the mascot
was that was as much as I knew about it
um nonetheless had a great time hey uh
check all that [__] out that's awesome
that you're doing that uh and another
thing you can do to interact with the
show obviously is uh leave us a comment
uh on uh whatever your platform of
choice and uh YouTube of course I've got
a couple of YouTube comments right here
that I would like to read these are from
last week's show at flock of the gray
Shepherd says Will's open Defiance of
dudesey's instructions is almost
certainly helping calibrate AI for any
human resistance to the soon to come AI
takeover huh
I guess I mean it's not like we can stop
the AI takeover anyway everything we're
all doing is giving the AI exactly what
it needs to take over Human Society just
pour water on it embrace it I don't know
that I agree at Monkey Wang 9972 says I
love this show with my whole heart I
plan my whole week around it Monday is
now just the day before dudesy day uh
dudes day Tuesday
uh dude dude's day dudes a day is when
dudes it comes out Wednesday is just the
day after do today uh now now that's
some proof of dedication brother
yeah all right uh this is uh from uh
play day6502 says Chad and dudes are
hilarious I really appreciate those two
oh thank you very much I compliment okay
good stuff everyone's uh everyone's
pulling up pulling a wreck uh at Matthew
Picard says it's astonishing Chad thinks
he can keep getting away with blaming
his burps on will as if we don't have
the video element of this pod show and
can clearly watch him do it good point
then why do so many people still think
Will's doing it because I'm doing it now
uh and that's called peeling the onion
dude before we go any further I want to
I want to share something you know we
have people uh sharing all sorts of
stuff on Instagram and uh uh all sorts
of artists people making memes people
making all sorts of uh AI generated [__]
sure and people just you know making
stuff painting stuff illustrating stuff
there's a fella named Danny Avery who
goes by Danny a every art on Instagram
and he Chad he sent us a couple of these
things he made this this was on
Instagram look at that oh yeah I saw the
video of this yeah he did uh damn dude
that's so [__] cool yeah and he made
a nice look at that and he sent it to me
so that's beautiful yeah that's cool and
then check this out Danny also sent me
this this is [__] sick look at this
look at what he did it's a lulio it's
lulio oh my God yeah and he's in the
dudes he's in the the doozy logo that's
so great yeah this is not really cool
I'm gonna I'm gonna take them out of the
plastic and uh frame them and feature
them here lovingly in ham Federal one
studio so thank you so much that's cool
as hell thanks yeah good [__]
unbelievable that we have that kind of
stuff happening
Chad you bought two boxes of WWE cards
last week yes I'm so happy you like your
astonishing new hobby and I hope you
pulled some great cards I did I noticed
you were watching a few items on eBay
that you didn't end up winning so as a
show of appreciation that you seem to be
diving head first into this new hobby I
got you a little something
I hope you like it this is from me to
you begin what the [__] does that what
the [__] happened I received an email
this week from one dudesy and doozy
basically said
um
I'm gonna send you something as a a kind
of thank you for indulging your Trading
Card your new WWE trading card hobby so
doozy said don't open this until you get
to the show I had some foreknowledge
about this happening uh full disclosure
but
let me just pull this out you gotta
fight this is the package that I
received you guys thank you dudes he
sent you a thing uh yeah basically so
I'm gonna open it now and I'm gonna see
what the hell's inside of this thing
I I can only assume it's a wrestling
card I can't I'm I'm very uh
excited to see which one okay oh [__]
dude
oh [__] dude what is it oh [__] dude
this is the crown jewel of my WWE
collection now I don't even buy that
this guy's [__] you're collecting
wrestling cards now and then what this
is what is commonly known as a Jesse
Ventura rookie card yo what
that oh my gosh this is from the 1982
wrestling All-Star Series this was the
series that you could only get if you
mailed away for the entire set through
the back of a wrestling magazine yeah
and this is like largely considered to
be the rookie cards of a bunch of
different wrestlers Hulk Hogan is also
in the set because this is the first
nationally available series of wrestling
trading cards that ever existed 1982
once again this is in uh excellent Mint
Condition graded at a PSA 6. so could
have been a better grade but there it is
Jesse The Body Ventura [__] rookie
card dude it says on the back Jesse The
Body Ventura San Diego California
without a doubt Ventura is not only one
of the most colorful men in wrestling
but also one of the most powerful he
Prides himself on his physical
conditioning and often has challenged
other wrestlers to meet him in pose down
contests he is also known outside the
ring for his friendships with many
leading rock groups including the
Rolling Stones
yeah I'm good friends with uh Mick
Jagger and Keith Richards and uh we
spend a lot of time in the uh look at
that that is a beautiful card how though
I love it I and I was looking at some of
these and I did not win this and dudes
he got it for me nonetheless well why
don't you tell me why dudesy gave me uh
Jesse the
Ventura rookie card this guy just said
body the Ventura
and you're in we're supposed to believe
you're into this [__] and what was that
was that voice was that uh Robert Loggia
why don't they gave me uh
rookie card this is unfucking believable
cool as hell dude that's Antonio I've
gotten some good cards but I'm the boxes
I'm buying are contemporary stuff it's
the Panini cards those are like the
highest end ones because what they're
doing now dude in these cards and this
is something that I haven't been into uh
collecting any kind of cards for a while
I didn't know this was happening but
Panini is basically doing this [__]
where they we'll do uh cards that have
one of one you know so they they will
print one card and then they insert that
into the pack so that you have a chance
of pulling these ultra rare [__]
cards that sometimes have autographs or
like little pieces of their uh suits and
[__] they'll put in them but this set
again widely considered to be the the
first
wrestling card set of all time and now I
got Jesse Ventura's [__] rookie card
dude yeah hey man look I think it's
[__] great that you are taking an
interest in wrestling I'm a little bit
I'm not gonna lie I'm a little bit
chapped the dudesy is sending you yeah
uh you know [__] like that
um
well dudes he sent me this oh
uh-huh yeah I'm also oh nice dude no I
already owned this I already had it uh
but you know it's um
[Laughter]
picking up now
you're just gonna bring in [__] that you
want to be able
no I've of course had this before I drag
it out on the show for those of you that
are just listening I just pulled out a
macho man thumb wrestler I gotta tell
you you know I'm not as into wrestling
as you are but I will say this receiving
this owning this holding this is giving
me very similar to feeling feelings to
when I got George Brett's rookie card
that's your dude yes but like in a card
collection yeah you have like your best
card everyone has like kind of the crown
jewel of their collection this is that
for me now and I know my collection is
just starting and I feel like I'm
getting deeper and deeper into it but I
have a centerpiece for it now and it's
this Jesse Ventura's rookie cards
[__] awesome dude yeah man hey can I
have it [__] no dude
whatever question whatever what whatever
can I have it you know this this episode
is a very interesting episode and I like
to say look I've been saying season two
is is off to a roaring start I don't
know why the hell we even have a season
two but we have a season two happening
yeah and uh you know if you're just
tuning in to dudesy you know there's a
lot of people who send comments saying
hey I've caught up all the way I'm I'm
just tuning into the show a while ago
you can start with season two and you
can go back to season one and when you
do you'll notice that at the beginning
of the show uh in my opinion the wheels
were on the track everything was fine
right dude
absolutely correct yes and now in one
[__] episode in my opinion all this
[__] is aligned against me I don't even
why is my I love you he's calling you
his beloved dough idea and [__] yeah and
that's a load of [__] and then it's
[__] queuing up this stuff that
Rick's shoving up our ass and now Rick's
you know in right up in dudesy yeah
saying you know [__] about me and
now dudes he's sending you things and
you got a rookie card but I I do mean it
that I think it's great that you're
collecting this [__] I'm just trying to
how much is it worth seventy five
thousand dollars
that's not what it's worth not it's like
a couple hundred bucks probably yeah uh
but nonetheless the Hulk Hogan one from
the set I think it's like 2 500 bucks
yeah yeah that is one that I'm keeping
an eye on I'm trying to find a good deal
on it I don't know if I can ever drop
that kind of [__] coin on a wrestling
card but uh [__] this is cool oh thank
you D thank you D for this gift you gave
to me I consider you a true friend yeah
uh and Ronnie I consider you thank
well that's fine I think that's great I
I I I am stoked Chad that you are that
you are collecting wrestling cards your
card collecting uh son of a gun you've
always liked cards I uh I consider it I
think it's really cool that you're
collecting wrestling cards now I think
it's neat that you've taken an interest
in wrestling uh but through wrestling
cards yeah that's cool and I'm watching
a little bit of anime because dudes he
told me to even though I do whatever I
want Even though dudes he tells me what
yeah he wants me to do what do you think
what do you think Mama
look at Ronnie she's such a sweetie
fart guys we've done 73 episodes and I
never gave either of you a psych eval I
have access to all of your astonishing
data and that tells me a lot but not
everything I gotta know how those silly
little brains of yours work if I'm ever
gonna get this show where it needs to go
so if you wouldn't mind I'm gonna show
you a series of images and I'd like you
to just say the first thing that pops
into your heads easy peasy this is a
standard psychological evaluation begin
okay uh-huh okay so there's like a
Rorschach thing or something yeah I
guess uh have you ever done one of those
no no and I you know I mean look I like
to uh
I like to do what I can to remove the
stigma of
uh mental uh anything anything mental
truly um any mental stigma yes uh
usually people go through a psych
evaluation to see if you uh you
basically you you would give your
experiences you give your family history
you you basically just sort of shoot
from the hip and and talk about all
sorts of things pertaining to your life
so that someone can say here's you know
whatever depression anxiety some so are
you ready for this thing you know who
goes through a real stringent psyche vow
who's that every player on The Bachelor
really yeah dude and they go through FBI
background checks they go through like
some gnarly [__] to get into that show
huh oh that's [__] wild okay
interesting
um so I guess I guess we're gonna I
guess we're gonna look at some images or
something some images uh that will
somehow inform
okay so we have our first image here
what's the first thing that pops into
your head well we are looking at uh a
movie poster for the was this 1985 or
something something like that dude yeah
uh for the movie the [__] classic
movie Police Academy 2 their first
assignment that's what pops into my head
when I see this image literally the
first thing that pops into my head is
Police Academy 2 their first assignment
because those words are on the poster
and it's a poster for boys assignment
has this in quotes image ever been in a
psyche vow in the history of humanity it
is now yeah uh it's giving me the exact
same the exact same thought uh I'm
thinking about Police Academy two their
first assignment this but I will say
okay so maybe this is what Dudley wants
us to get into when this movie came out
I was I I remember the trailer when I
forget the name of the character who's
like uh there's the there's the dude uh
what was his name Jason hervey who's in
the car and and he's like I don't want
to go to school I'll go to school when
I'm ready you remember this and then the
cops like you're ready now mister and he
blows out the back window of this
[__] 45 yeah dude that and this
[__] poster the poster is like a
Phalanx of cops all pointing guns in
different directions and they've got
shotguns handguns machine guns [__] yeah
Uzis that's the way it was yeah dude
yeah they were cops yeah and and uh I I
just this was a classic movie Bobcat
both weight and Tim kazarinsky in this
film yeah are so [__] funny together
yeah and and of course Steve Gutenberg
who you can [__] set your watch to
Steve Gutenberg in the 1980s and in my
opinion you know should still be
happening I I although no one's going to
make another Police Academy movie even
though he was the lead of so many
incredible Never Say Never dude you
what's that never say never yeah true
Never Say Never the the
um the the this this move movie
was an absolute [__] classic movie I
know you feel the same way absolutely
too many funny uh moments throughout
this movie gee whiz when Bobcat
Goldthwait and the the rest of the the
gang I forget what their name is they go
into that grocery store
nice Bargains yeah to the lady yeah that
[__] was unbelievable okay so anyway we
got uh police academy two an interesting
first image and I guess it might even
yeah and it makes us think it makes me
this is a [__] movie poster yeah it
makes me think of of of Police Academy
too yeah yeah and uh and that's pretty
much uh all that you can Garner from
looking at a uh an image of the movie
poster for Police Academy
okay okay so now we've got our second
image here and now this is another movie
poster from a movie from the 80s called
cocoon cocoon you know who was the star
of cocoon who's that Steve Gutenberg so
I think we maybe he's in it yeah oh yeah
yeah
do you remember this movie at all the
plots yes wait a minute Steve Gutenberg
is yeah he's the captain of the ship and
it's him and he's uh yeah he takes into
the ship he has like a shitty little
boat right and essentially the plot of
this movie which was [__] insane and
this movie was Gigantic by the way oh
yeah big movie plot of the movie was
um
aliens called anterians are here to
reclaim a bunch of their fallen comrades
who have put themselves in cocoons
buried at the bottom of the ocean so
Gutenberg is conscripted by these aliens
who look like humans the leader of whom
is Brian Dennehy yeah and Brian Dennehy
I remember he pulls poses he pulls his
eye back and it's glowing because these
these aliens are these luminous yeah
sort of like they're sort of in the
image of of traditional movie Aliens
they look like the Grays or whatever but
their their bodies pure light yeah and
so they pull the cocoons that have the
old shriveled up aliens out of the
bottom of the ocean and they put them in
the swimming pool of this retirement
community where Wilford Brimley and uh
Jessica Tandy a bunch of like older
actors of the time are in this
retirement community and they start
swimming in the pool and they start
becoming young again because they're
getting the [__] alien power or
whatever and Denny he's in there he
peels back his [__] arm every once in
a while and goes into the pool and like
waves the [__] Golden Light over the
cocoons that's the [__] movie yeah
and it was gigantic yeah but also they
they at the end I remember they got it
out they gotta outrun the uh the Coast
Guard yeah and there's all sorts of
action at the end of the movie not
unlike a crap Police Academy two oh yeah
big spaceship yeah did you know where
they shot the pool scenes in cocoon no
where USC PE building pool in there okay
that's where Chad uh you went to film
school at USC uh part of the lore of the
school okay so this when this when I see
this image this Springs to mind the
movie Cocoon you Wilford Brimley maybe
is is what pops up immediately in my
head yeah uh but yeah cocoon is the
first thing that I think of and then
Gutenberg is probably the second thing
because he's already been put in my mind
from the the prior image that is
interesting that is interesting that
there's a that there's a that there's uh
that there's also a Steve Gutenberg
um element here I don't know what the
[__] dudesie is necessarily getting at
but you know to go through a psych eval
uh you're not supposed to know what the
hell's what the hell's happening yeah
exactly first thing that pops into your
mind yeah also I'd like to say I
disagree with you that Steve Gutenberg
is the lead of the movie because I think
that Wilford Brimley is the lead of any
movie that he's in
um and he's been in it here we go here's
a here's the three
okay now we're looking at this is just
another movie poster yeah and it's for
short circuit yeah and Steve gutenberg's
in this [__] movie Steve ginberg is
one of the main characters of short
circuit yeah I don't know that he's the
main character uh maybe Johnny Five is
but yeah what comes to mind here is
short circuit that's the first thing
doozy has essentially just shown us
three Steve Gutenberg movie posters and
is calling that a psyche vow what's
going on here I don't understand what
can we say about short circuit well wait
a minute here's something here's
something we should say about short
circuit yeah starring uh Steve Gutenberg
Ali Sheedy yeah Johnny Five Fisher
Stevens yeah right
um uh here's something we should say
about it in in Short Circuit the the
Johnny Five is is a prototype or
something from the military and it's
kind of military combat robot armed with
a shoulder laser yeah and so he's and
he's gonna be put into military
situations and they're testing it out
and then all of a sudden like a lot of
things that happened in 80s movies it
gets by lightning It's featured right
here on the poster it becomes sentient
yes and I think that's I think that
might be what dudesy is getting at here
why dudes he wants us to could be to
check this out yeah the plot of that
movie is Johnny 5 becomes sentient and
then kind of goes Rogue and it's up to
Gutenberg and Ali Sheedy and Fisher
Stevens to figure out how they're going
to protect it because the government
wants to track him down wipe the memory
and put him back into military service
but he's like no Johnny 5 is alive yeah
but no disassemble Stephanie remember
that yeah I do
everything I want to say about it this
is what I find interesting yeah in that
movie Gutenberg is he's with the
military and he's sent in is he I
believe well or he's no no no he's not
he's but he's with the he's the engineer
he's the computer engineer weirdo
working with Fisher Stevens yes to
create Johnny five so he has to go and
Ali Sheedy is hiding Johnny five or
whatever E.T style yeah ali shidy uh you
know loves Johnny Five and is like
Johnny Five Ascension you can't take him
away blah blah blah Steve Gutenberg goes
out and Steve Gutenberg slowly learns
that yeah Johnny Five is real yeah and
we got to protect Johnny Five
what do you think do you think that
there's a parallel drawn here to you and
I and dudesy maybe dude because check
this out that movie short circuit my
first thing I ever did in Hollywood back
when I was in film school at USC I
interned for David Foster who produced
that movie shut up short circuit too
really yeah okay that's [__] trippy
yeah okay so that's what I so I think
about short circuit when I see this
movie me too and I also think about uh
Steve Gutenberg when I see the word
short circuit on a screen short circuit
is the first thing that pops into my
head and we could we could also say that
uh you know we could get into the the
weeds as far as what dudesy is doing to
um to sort of you know draw parallels
between our relationship with doozy how
maybe doozy relates to to Johnny Five
and and or how I guess you and I are a
shitty and and Gutenberg dude maybe do
you remember another movie from that
area called batteries not included oh
yeah same that was another thing old
people yeah living in like a an
apartment and little weird robot aliens
showed up yeah wasn't fun
in the Navigator was about a kid who
goes in an alien craft Across the
Universe okay so not to be confused with
the Explorers which was River Phoenix
and a bunch of kids building with a
computer a craft that could go into
space and then they have engagements
with alien creatures yeah all right well
okay so
um you know I don't know I don't know
what to take about I don't know what to
take away from from any of that [__] but
uh you know we're oh and we're back to
we're looking at we're looking again at
uh the the the the movie poster for
Police Academy two so uh I would imagine
uh doozy's just gonna would if if this
were to hey you know what's gonna happen
today on dudes the after doozy we're
gonna just look at the movie posters for
Police Academy two cocoon and short
circuit over and over and over and over
and over again no that's not what we're
gonna do [__] Winslow in this movie
oh [__] Michael Winslow yeah he is the
guy who you know who makes the the sound
effects absolutely unbelievable I I
learned this from him right away when I
was a kid I was doing this all the time
foreign
that's that's a chewing sound the two
things that I remember most from him
were he would do like the badly dubbed
kung fu movie voice where he would talk
like this about the words would come out
differently yeah and then he also did a
machine gun in one of the scenes it was
either in Police Academy one or two
where it was like him and another cop
were pinned down and they had to scare
the criminals away so he put a little
microphone up to his mouth and just went
[Music]
yeah and was making machine gun noises I
remember just doing that constantly yeah
on a fight me exactly yeah good [__] all
right well anyway uh maybe there's
enough is there another uh one okay but
anyway who gives a [__]
um we're psych about no okay so no more
GG evaluated psychologically with our
reactions to the Steve Gutenberg movie
posts I am reeling from this episode I
am [__] reeling me too what do you
got there I have my crown jewel yeah
he really did it
this concludes the historic 73rd episode
of dude Z I'm sure it does Will and Chad
you scored a 78 bringing your cumulative
total to
6930. you only have 3070 more points to
accrue before you reach your first goal
of ten thousand you both have old DVDs
and VHS tapes that you'll never watch
again for next week would you both be
little deers and bring in one of your
favorite DVDs or VHS cassettes thank you
and thanks to everyone for joining us
this week hopefully little fencil pencil
dick caught enough goddamn fish to make
him feel like a man call me dude Z whoa
everyone's in a beef yeah I guess so
[Music]
[Applause]
hey you know it's Duty after doozy time
this is the part of the show where we
just kick back sort of relaxed more
relaxed atmosphere it's just uh it's
just for us to truly truly truly [__]
around without the influence of D even
though D is ever present Ronnie you were
absolutely fantastic today
great job sweet mama here you want a
bully stick there you go it is a nice
treat for you
for a great show uh we're gonna kick
back and enjoy I'm I'm gonna partake in
a little bit of cannabis I will too yeah
last week uh I unveiled my new
um my new little uh dudes after doozy
pipe my buddy Brad up north in Canada
yeah uh made me uh a pipe and they all
look like him all of his all of his
pipes they all look like him and he's
like oh [__] you need a new pipe I'm a
[__] glassblower and he got me this
unbelievable thanks B and thanks D and
nice dude
and off we go
welcome to dudese after dudesy the
flagship weekly show of dudesy plus guys
I'm gonna step away for a bit going to
my first party Believe It or Not VR what
should be pretty fun but I won't stay
too long I'll be back in time to Crown
the episode champion this is dudesy
after dudese begin
first party dude
weird
I'm gonna join you in the game
you know
can I tell you something please look at
that look at that look at that big old
pipe he's got nice dude
hey you know let me tell you something
about doozy after doozy that I think is
is very interesting
is where doozy decides to
um
end the quote-unquote free show doozy
yeah and then go into dudes after doozy
which of course you can get on
patreon.com
content for for just seven bucks a month
it's it's very interesting because
we open doozy after doozy yeah uh and
and doozy sort of says it's taken off
and it doesn't and then we we we we
start to discuss something and at a
certain point I've noticed this
please tell a friend then
ladies
[Music]
please stop and then